second dose walk-ins now being accepted
at the convention center
this according to the health district
they're from 8 a.m to 2 p.m but you must
have had your first modernity dose
between january 4th and 9th it is
complicated joe mohler there today where
he talked to some
really frustrated people who are
actually trying to get a first dose joe
there's so many moving parts with this
yeah a lot of people are confused well
today we came out here for about an
hour's time when we were really trying
to talk to someone who was coming for a
walk-in and trying to get that vaccine
but instead we
ran into a number of folks who were
walking up to this fence and talking to
a southern nevada health district
employee and
were being turned away because their
first dose appointments were cancelled
well i'm frustrated because i came all
the way from henderson to get this
because henderson ran out
some valley residents came to the
convention center with first dose
appointments friday only to learn the
appointments were canceled
so i was turned away and i'm very upset
there's a bunch of people up there with
me having the same issues
we spoke to several people who as you
can imagine left a little irritated
get organized get more people on the
phones i waited an hour and a half to
talk to somebody today to
confirm this thursday the health
district announced if you made a first
dose appointment at the convention
center it will not happen here
only second dose appointments and some
walk-ins are being accepted over the
next four weeks
i wouldn't have taken off work and i
wouldn't have been here if i had gotten
the cancellation
a health district representative told me
cancellations were sent out
if you are planning to come to a walk-in
you must have had the first moderna
vaccine at a health district location
between january 4th
and 9th some were supposedly coming to
appointments that were set too soon and
being told to come back at a later date
mara like many others is worried about
getting a second dose on time
this was the only appointment i could
get
with two weeks of trying
and i'm back at her live again this
location of the convention center is
only for the modern
vaccine the second dose that is and i'll
be doing those walk-ins
for the next four weeks i'll send it
back to you and joe
did the people who were turned away get
appointments set up for that dose did
that happen
uh no they were told to uh try and come
back on a walk-in closer to that date or
on that date they were given that card
on the first day
uh first a dose that they were given
there's a date on there and they were
told to come back for a walk-in
on those dates or try and set up an
appointment again online but as you know
many people are having a hard time
doing that all right thanks so much joe
and we will stay all over this story
because it's a daily thing